it is going to make the early weeks of
the season even more interesting than
they ordinarily would have been and
here's the thing last year even though
we had an off-season program and a
preseason there were still some
significant injuries early in the season
and one guy who was injured
in pre-season playing in new england as
the starting quarterback of the panthers
and that injury continued to get worse
until he was shut down for the full
season after a thursday night debacle
against tom brady's buccaneers
cam newton now
the starting quarterback of the new
england patriots it was reported
yesterday afternoon he'd be the starter
the team didn't announce he'd be the
starter what the team announced is he's
one of the captains
there's no way he's one of the captains
if he isn't the starter you don't make a
guy who may be benched or a guy who's
got a tenuous grip on the starting job
or a guy who isn't number one on the
depth chart a team
captain look this cam newton experiment
shireen has gone exactly the way that
that the patriots had hoped the way that
the rest of the afc east and the rest of
the conference had feared and the way
that i think we all agreed if cam newton
is healthy it could go the real question
with cam newton is he healthy and i
think that there were so many teams out
there
that
that you know their quarterback position
is set
but
they're starting quarterback when
healthy isn't nearly as good as cam
newton when healthy and i think that's
one of the reasons why there wasn't the
interest is he healthy do we want to go
down this path of upsetting our
quarterback apple cart and it all came
down to the patriots late june out of
nowhere in they come they signed cam
newton and so far so good now it may all
change when the games are played but
i think at this point
everything we've seen everything he's
done everything that's been said the
superlatives that have been foisted upon
him by coach bill belichick it's been a
rousing success so far
yeah mike this is a super bowl envy uh
league mvp who started a super bowl this
is a very accomplished quarterback that
they got for next to nothing it's an
incentive laden deal with a maximum of
7.5 million if he does everything he
expected and
and look the patriots will gladly pay
that if if he wins lingam vp and they go
to the super bowl and and all of that i
mean it's truly been a great year for
for the patriots and they've made a
seamless transition uh but yeah he he
was always expected to win this job
that's why they signed him i mean
jarrett stenham for all their talk in
the off season we're gonna be okay with
jarrett said and we're gonna be okay
with jared stidham i mean this guy's
made four passes in his career you don't
know what you have and jared stidham and
the fact that jared simon went to the
hospital i think cam really seized that
time up until that point they were
splitting snaps the three of the
quarterbacks brian hoyer jarrett stidham
and cam newton and then jarrett stidham
went to the hospital for that leg injury
that
appeared to be okay once he went to the
hospital have it checked out
but cam sees that time and sees the
starting quarterback job just as we all
thought he would and he is the most
accomplished to those three guys and
he's going to start off as a guy can he
stay healthy that's the big question
and i think part of the goal all along
was to prod cam newton not to just be
better than jared stidham and brian
hoyer but to be cam newton to be
incredibly great to be the guy that he
was in 2015 when he won the league mvp
award and you know it's a long time ago
and it's been a long time since we've
seen healthy cam newton and i think
that's the counterbalance
to how well everything has gone
on paper on film not that we have any
that we have access to but the patriots
looking at everything he's done feeling
good about it when it's time to go out
there and play when it's time to go out
there and potentially get hit what are
the patriots doing by way of
constructing an offense that maybe
doesn't put him in harm's way that
doesn't yield to the temptation to have
him jump over the top of the pile at the
one yard line take advantage of that
incredible physical stature and remember
that this is a guy whose 2018 season was
ultimately
destroyed by an injured shoulder 2019
the foot got him early and the foot
ended up taking him down in week two
it's been a long time since we've seen
cam newton firing on all cylinders and
the patriots need to have a plan shireen
in order to ensure that he'll be healthy
whether it's teaching him how to avoid
contact when he's in the passing game
how to avoid contact when he's running
the football maybe he's not going to
have a lot of designed runs but i think
bill and i look we got to give bill
belichick the benefit of the doubt here
he's smart enough to understand it if we
understand it he clearly understands it
at a much higher level than we do you've
got to keep this guy healthy or it is
going to be jared stidham or brian hoyer
playing quarterback this year
yeah that that's the key for cam newton
we've known that the last two years he's
hasn't been healthy and the panthers
weren't very good which is why they
moved on from him
this season and sought a different
quarterback and a different way to go
and you know it seems like every year in
cam newt's career we're talking about
all right he's got to get down he's got
to slide he's got to protect himself and
hopefully over the last two years being
injured first with the shoulder and then
with the foot that he's learned that
that he's an older more mature
quarterback i hope we all learn those
things mike as we mature and get older
and learn to be better and wiser at
things and you know it's time for cam
newton to do that to get out of harm's
way and get rid of the football but tom
brady was very good in that offense of
getting rid of the football and cam
newton's got to be the same thing
because they need him on the field i
don't think they're the same team with
jarrett stidham with brian hoyer a
journeyman i think they have to have cam
newton if they want to continue to be
the team that they've been which is a
dominant team in the afc east and a
dominant team in the afc a contender
every single year and i think bill
belichick thinks he can be that team he
can be a contender in the afc
one thing i was told several weeks ago
when josh mcdaniels was the head coach
in denver and remember he drafted tim
tebow in 2010 he had begun constructing
an offense for tim tebow and
even though mcdaniels wasn't there by
the time tebow became the starter and
the following year somehow led the
broncos the final eight
an offense was put together that is
conducive to a mobile quarterback that
that keeps him out of harm's way with
the designed runs you now look the
blocking is going to be a key part of it
but the way mcdaniels put it together a
decade ago the thinking is if they can
learn it and execute it properly that's
one of the things that will help keep
cam newton healthy but but that's the
key and you know we're going to get
caught up in how great cam looks and
he's going to be healthy until he isn't
but that's going to be the key can he
keep
what has been happening going by staying
out of harm's way by staying healthy and
and who knows maybe earning every penny
of that 7.5 million and if he earns
every penny of that 7.5 million it will
be the greatest level that any team has
ever
ever ever done because it will mean as a
practical matter he's been the regular
season mvp
and the super bowl mvp that's how he's
that's his path as a practical matter to
seven and a half million and then they
have the proverbial good problem to have
next year when they try to figure out
how to pay him for 2021 because he's
going to want to be paid for what he did
in 2020 if all those things happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports